Riktigt bra chefer har ju landat i förståelsen att det inte handlar om dom själva och så, utan att det är på något vis.
Ledarskap handlar om att få med sig människor för att nå verksamhetens mål.
Det är ju inte svårare än så.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag sitter vi här med Kalle Flör från chef och chefakademin.
Det blir väl en uppläxning av alla om vilka fruktansvärda ledare vi är.
Jag lutar tillbaks och nyttjar lite självspäkning.
Hur står det till Kalle?
Jo, tack.
Det är bra.
Det är väldigt bra, extra bra nu när man ska få späka Sveriges entreprenörer och chefer.
Nej, det ska vi verkligen försöka inte göra.
Känner du att folk typ försöker låta duktiga när de pratar med dig?
Ja, det tror jag nog.
Dels är jag i en kontext där vi verkligen lyfter fram det goda ledarskapet väldigt mycket.
Så då blir det väldigt mycket att man pratar med personer som är väldigt duktiga chefer redan.
Men det är klart att det kan säkert förekomma att folk...
Det är svårt att kanske bara outa sig alls för mycket när man pratar med någon som är mig.
Men jag tror jag sätter mest press på mig själv egentligen.
Jag är också chef själv och inte bara en expert.
Jag är TF vd för ett bolag med 40 medarbetare och lika många konsulter ungefär.
Det är klart att det är en utmaning och lite spännande att vara chef i en sån miljö där man är omgiven av väldigt erfana och duktiga ledarskapsutvecklare.
Man får ju höra ganska snabbt om man underlevererar på ledarskapsfronten.
Kan vi inte snacka lite om det först för det är en ganska spännande fråga.
Kan du liksom blockas i huvudet?
Jag tror jag kunde göra det vid när jag var ny som chef.
Då tror jag att jag upptogs ganska mycket av sådana tankar.
Vem är jag?
Hur ska jag vara?
Man sprang till H&M och köpte en bil i Kawaii för det skulle man ju ha som chef ungefär.
Men med åren har jag någonstans insett att det viktigaste och bästa ledarskapsgiften man kan ge någon och sig själv är ju att vara sig själv.
Då var vi klara.
Nej men jag skrev en krönika om det där.
När jag var ny som chef så gick jag till en coach för jag hade skitsvårt att ta med an chefskålen.
Jag såg mig inte alls som chef, jag hade inte varit chef, jag ville inte bli chef.
Jag såg mig själv som en gammal hiphopjournalist.
Helt plötsligt skulle man vara chef över andra chefer.
Det var mitt steg, jag blev vice vd i ett bolag.
Över en natt.
Jag hade jättesvårt att ha med an den där rollen.
Då minns jag att när coachen tittade mig i ögonen och sa vad är du rädd för?
Gör din grej, vad är det värsta som kan hända?
Det tog lite tid men det föddes något i att man måste inte följa den här mallen och vara på ett visst sätt bara för att man har fått den här rollen.
Det handlar om att vara genuin och vara autentisk.
Det kan man bara vara om man någonstans embrasar både sina styrkor och svagheter och är en människa på något vis i det hela.
Så det är väl det någonstans.
Jag har nog landat ganska mycket i det.
Att inte vara, att släppa den där perfektionismen på något vis.
Men har du reflekterat över, för du sa att det gick lite över en natt, har du reflekterat över vad de som rekryterade in i den rollen såg i dig?
Ja nej men då var det nog mycket att jag hade bevisat mig själv rent affärsmässigt.
Jag var digital chef då och drev utvecklingen av alla våra digitala produkter.
Det gått ganska bra, vi hade vunnit massa priser.
Det började, det var ju i mediebranschen då, det här var runt 2017.
Det var ju den här digitala transformationen som var högst på allas agenda.
Där hade jag bevisat mig, och det är också väldigt vanligt, det är ju ofta som man blir chef, att man inte för att man har visat ledaregenskaper, utan för att man har excellerat inom sin expertis på något vis.
Plötsligt förväntas man då också kunna leda människor utan att förstå att det är inte säkert att bara för att man har varit grym på att designa en skivställning eller bygga en app, så är man helt plötsligt bra på att leda andra människor.
Det handlar ju så mycket om att kunna tolka beteenden och att kunna skapa entusiasm och att vara lyhörd och inlyssnande och allt det där.
Ofta är man kanske inte det.
Om man har varit grym på att bara köra på och bygga upp någonting, då kanske man...
Det är inte alltid...
Om jag ser till mig själv i alla fall, det kräver kanske mycket av mig att bli en mer inlyssnande person och inte bara köra på på min grej.
Tycker du egentligen att vi borde ha nån sorts fristående chefskola där folk lär sig bli chefer?
Hade det varit bättre än så som det funkar nu?
Det som är viktigare är att man inte tar det för givet.
Jag hörde ett webbinas om förra veckan om vikten av hur man ska lyckas.
Alla snackar om tvärfunktionellt samarbete men det är lätt att snacka om.
Det är två som får till det.
Någon forskare på Handelshögskolan sa att problemet är att vi bara tar det för givet, samarbete.
Det är bara att nu ska ni samarbeta.
Men vad är det då?
Vi utbildar ingen i samarbete.
Vi pratar inte ens om samarbete.
Det är väl lite samma med ledarskap, att man ofta tar det för givet.
Där kan jag tycka att tidningen Schäf, där jag är chefredaktör, har funnits sen 1995.
Då, genidraget för de som startade den tidningen var att man såg den här gruppen på marknaden som var sjukt ensam.
Och som dessutom var ganska köpstark.
Man hade tjänstebil och man gillade vin och resor.
Det var The Golden Age för annonsörer.
Men någonstans identifierade man den här målgruppen som ingen riktigt hade sett.
Och då har ju också man på något vis, under den här 30 åren så har ju chef och ledarskap någonstans blivit en profession i sig.
Alltså man har på något vis uppgraderat och uppvärderat de egenskaperna och beteenden som skapar bra ledare.
Och det har nästan, nu kan man ju växla.
Det finns ju chefer som har gått från, alltså man växlar branscher hejvilt.
Så länge man är duktig på att få ihop bolag, bygga bolag, få ihop team och skapa resultat, så kan man liksom jobba med lite vad som helst.
Så det är nog lite nytt tror jag.
Tidigare var det nog att du som sagt var en expert och så växte du i den vertikalen.
Så det är väl skillnaden egentligen att man ser att det har professionaliserats på något vis, på chefsrollen.
Men jag gissar att det jag dåvarande vd såg, att jag var liksom just det här.
Många människor är väldigt bra på att snacka och måla upp strategier.
Men det är inte alltid säkert att man också får saker gjorda.
Jag tror att det är väl det som är nyckeln att man också både kan snacka och genomföra förändringar och driva saker och så.
Jag tror att om man har personer som har den kombinationen kan det ofta bli ganska bra i ledarroller.
Hur tror du att de här första kollegorna som du blev chef över, hur tror du att de såg dig första året?
Då var det lite speciellt, tror jag, eftersom jag också blev...
Jag hade inte varit chef innan och seglade förbi några andra personer som kanske nog själva såg sig som mer naturliga vd-ar än jag.
Så det var väl dels det.
Det fanns säkert de som tyckte det var jättekul och bra, men det fanns nog också de som själva tyckte att ja men, det borde varit dom.
Och så har det väl i alla organisationer, att det finns en sådan tävling.
Och då gäller det väl någonstans att...
Ja, det kan man inte lägga så jättemycket energi på, utan man får ju bara försöka göra sin grej och ha ett bra relation med sin egen chef om vart man ska och jobba framåt.
Och försöka, ja, prove them wrong.
Men jag tror att, nej men det var väl, nej det gick ganska bra, det var nog rätt friktionsfritt.
Det är inte så många som har sagt något i alla fall.
Utan det var nog mer jag själv och mina egna norgor och osäkerhet som spelade in i det.
Och det är också det vi ser, alltså alla undersökningar vi gör i tidningschef och chefakademin och alla chefer vi träffar och vi gör massor av ledarskapsutbildningar hela dagarna.
58 utbildningar som vi genomförde bara i februari runtom i Sverige.
Frågan är typ att alla chefer ställer sig är, dyger jag.
Och man känner sig som en bluff, det är ju det här imposter syndrome, pratar man om bluffsyndromet.
Alla i princip oavsett bransch eller erfarenhet känner sig, att de skulle bara veta.
Om man slutar från roll och sätter över sida ihop platsalonsen till den som ska ersätta en, så tror jag att ganska många har tänkt såhär, att jag skulle aldrig få mitt gamla jobb själv, om jag sökte det.
Ofta är det omständigheter som leder till att man hamnar i en viss roll, om man gör så gott man kan.
Men jag tror att många går runt med den där naggande känslan av att man inte riktigt är tillräckligt bra.
Det tror jag inte alla medarbetare alltid uppfattar, att man som chef förväntas man ge feedback hela tiden, men det är ganska få som ger en feedback tillbaka.
Det är en ganska ensam roll, om man inte har nätverk, forum och chefskollegor omkring sig.
Det är nog väldigt viktigt att skapa det om man inte har det.
Är det en ny grej att chefen måste få feedback och känslor tillbaka?
Jag har svårt att tänka mig att min gammelfar, för nu vet jag inte vad han jobbar med, men jag har svårt att tänka mig att någon från 1870-talet gick runt och tänkte, varför fick jag inte feedback om min kolleg här igår?
Är vi så känsliga idag även?
Jag tror att det som har kännetecknat, det svenska ledarskapet pratar man ju ofta om då, och då är det ju det här med att det ska vara demokratisk ledarstil och tillit, man ska fatta beslut tillsammans och så.
I det ligger ju mycket känslor och det blir mycket psykologi i det, så var det ju inte 1870-talet då var det nog mer pekar med hela handen.
Och det där skapar ju också problem idag.
Jag vet att vi gjorde i genomförde bolaget, jag jobbar i en funktion för två år sedan, fyra år sedan, två bolag som slogs ihop.
Och då var det en medarbetare som var jätteupprörd och sa till mig att det här märks, att det här är inte någon demokrati.
Och sen är det ju inte det.
Ett bolag är ju inte en demokrati, det finns ju hierarkiska strukturer.
Sen är det klart att man ska lyssna på varandra, där man fattar beslut tillsammans.
Men det kan ju ibland bli en övertro på att det är en demokratiklubb eller i det här platta.
Men till syvende och sista är det ju någon som beslutar.
Det finns ju en aktiebolagslag att förhålla sig till med en styrelse som ska tillsätta och avsätta en vd som i sin tur genomför de direktiv som ägarna sätter upp.
Blablabla.
Så är det ju någonstans.
Men när det ska vara det här mjuka, så tror jag också att det kanske blir skapats en förväntan i många organisationer om att man behöver ju, vill man behålla medarbetare och vill ha en bra kultur så behöver man jobba med de här frågorna, feedback och sånt.
Det har ju också forskningen visat, det hade man kanske inte förstått riktigt då, på gammelfarfas tid.
Finns det någon perfekt symbiose för att absolut alla ska komma till tal, så man ska ha åsikter, men det finns ju också människor som tycker om att bara, fan vad skönt att någon tar tag i detta och jag slipper ta ansvar för detta.
I alla fall framför någon som håller folk runt ryggen och säger att det är lugnt, jag täcker upp skiten här så kör vi igen.
Det finns ju båda sidor.
Finns det någon forskning eller finns det något land eller någon region som är så här, här verkar anställda må bäst och här verkar forskningen säga att här är de mest effektiva kontra hur folk mår.
Finns det något sådant?
På global skala vet jag inte men man brukar lyfta fram just den svenska ledarskapsmodellen som väldigt framgångsrik.
Vi har ju sett bolag som Spotify, Klama, Skype och Gymkompaniets.
De här stora globala framgångsdagar som Sverige har byggt har ju kännetecknats, dels om man pratar om såklart innovationskraft och sådant, men det är väl mycket just den här ledarstilen som vi har i Sverige.
Det som egentligen Jan Carlsson med sin Tjåskvältare, rivpyramiderna, det var ju där det började någonstans, att man skulle prata mer om att ta bort silos, jobba med plattorganisationer, man ska jobba med delegering, man ska jobba med tillit, man ska fatta beslut tillsammans.
Det tar mer tid men då har man ju hela gänget med sig och då blir det väldigt mycket lättare att nå resultat.
Det har ju forskningen någonstans visat att den effekten finns.
Men sen hur det står sig globalt, vi ser ju en rörelse just nu mot någonting helt annat.
Apropå det du sa i din fråga där, att man kan inte nån bara, just där med tydlighet.
Vi ser ju Trump, Orban är unga, när då han i trikriet, putt in i Ryssland en rörelse mot auktoritära ledare.
Det var klippte mig för ett tag sedan, och då sa frisören, uttryckte jag det helt frustrerat, kan det inte bara komma någon politiker som säger det i alla tycker?
Då kan man skratta lite åt det.
Men den känslan i en sjukt rörig värld, kan man ju också förstå att vi vill ha de här tydliga ledarfigurerna.
Och det här med det allt jag har rablat är ju lite motsatsen till det.
Så det är klart att det där är ju något som...
Men vi vet ju också vad som ger resultat.
Det är ju som sagt att man jobbar på det sättet.
Att man i organisationer som präglas av tillit och med humanistiska värderingar där man någonstans ändå tar jämställdhets-
och mångfalds-
och inkluderingsarbete på allvar.
Det ska man inte bara göra för att man är godhetsknarkare, utan forskningen visar också att det ger effekt på sista raden.
Så det är därför vi någonstans behöver fortsätta att driva de frågorna, även om man ser teckningen i omvärlden på att det är på väg åt det andra hållet.
Så där är det ju, det går ju i cykler hela tiden.
Ja.
Ja, jag bara funderar på, det började med vad dina chefer såg i dig när de tillsatte dig.
20 minuter senare, nej det är väl det.
Kan vi inte ta, vi ska komma in på allt sådant här också, men kan du inte bara förklara för oss lite snabbt vad tidningen och chef liksom omfattar och även vad chefsakter min omfattar, bara så vi får en kontext på vart du jobbar och vad du gör.
Absolut, absolut.
Det här sitter jag och babblar på.
Man är så van och road av att prata om de här sakerna så det är lättare att hamna där.
Nej men, tidningen Chef är ju en Sveriges eller Nordens största ledarskaps-tidning som kommer ut med 11 nummer per år i print, men som också har chef.se och vårt abonnemang.
Chefhacket.me plus, vi gör webbinas och vi gör event i Almedalen och vi har något som heter Chefdagen som är ett av Sveriges största ledarskaps-events.
Det är målet med Chef är att bli den naturliga startpunkten egentligen för alla som intresserar sig för ledarskap.
Den har funnits då som sagt i 30 år.
Målet är att inspirera, lyfta goda exempel, lyfta frågor som är viktiga för chefer och ledare idag.
Det är väldigt spännande eftersom det räcker att sluta upp en dagstidning eller sätta på en nyhetssändning för att förstå att ledarskap är centralt för alla utmaningar som vår tid står inför.
Sen är Chefhacket.me bolaget.
Det är det bolaget som bildades för två år sedan.
M-gruppen som är ett superanrikt utbildningsbolag som har funnits sedan 1931 och har gjort management och ledarskapsutbildning, utveckling, både skrädd avsida och upplag för företag men också såhär, ni som chef, YGL, allt det här som man känner till som kurser och utbildningar.
Men också digitala appskill som såhär, så tar du an AI som ledare och så där.
Och till Executive MBA, där är det egentligen vi och Handels och Stockholms universitet som erbjuder det, alltså den här typen av stora långa program som sträcker sig över ett år eller två, där man verkligen får en MBA-utbildning egentligen.
Det erbjuder då M-gruppen.
Så när vi gifte ihop de här två bolagen, chef och M-gruppen, så blev det chefakademin.
Det handlar ju om att vara där chefen finns och erbjuda det chefen behöver.
Att bli liksom ett one stop shop.
Oavsett om du, var du befinner dig på din ledarskapsresa.
Om du är helt ny som chef och behöver lära dig grunderna, eller om du har varit chef länge och behöver uppskilla dig eller utbilda dig ännu mer, eller du vill göra karriär inom organisationen och utveckla dig i ledningsgruppen, eller vad den kan vara, så finns vi där liksom.
Vad är det du går igång på?
Det är ganska bred.
Går du igång på att vara, utveckla, eller liksom lära om chefskap och ledarskap, eller går du igång på hela den här stora organismen av att ni ska finnas överallt, eller skriveriet eller infon.
Vad är din, för du är ju uppenbart passionerad detta.
Nej men jag är ju, jag har en kul fråga.
Jag är ju journalist i grunden, jag har jobbat som det, nyhetsjournalist, musik-
och kulturjournalist i 20 år.
Så det är ju min bakgrund, och det är klart att jag brinner jättemycket för det kreativa, att stå på scen och skriva, och det tycker jag ju personligen är väldigt roligt, men det som gör att jag har stannat i det här bolaget så länge, och det är ju att bygga bolaget.
Och jag tror att alla vi som jobbar här är väldigt värderingsstyrda.
Alltså det handlar ju mycket om att vi tror ju verkligen i djupet av våra hjärtan på att att ett gott, ja men vår tagline är så här, bra ledare förändrar världen.
Och det låter ju väldigt svulstigt och stort, men det behöver inte bara vara den stora vidare världen, det kan ju vara den liksom lilla världen, vi alla påverkas av ledarskap.
Det finns ju också forskning som visar att typ utöver ens partner så finns ju ingen som påverkar ens välmående så mycket som chefen.
Så att om vi har bra chefer och lyckas hjälpa till att förbättra förutsättningarna för chefer och ledare så blir ju hela samhället bättre.
Alltså i stort.
Man blir en bättre förälder, man blir en bättre partner, man blir bättre på alla möjliga sätt och vis om man liksom får arbetslivet att fungera.
Och där har ju cheferna en viktig roll.
Så det är det som driver mig väldigt mycket.
Och där tror jag att man behöver förstå.
I det kommer det ju in det här med det livslånga lärandet, för att använda en klyska liksom.
Men det handlar ju om att så här, man kan lätt prata om så här, vi föräldrarfällan.
Alltså det är inte så jättemånga tonårsföräldrar som fortfarande prenumererar på vi föräldrar.
För man kanske köper den tidningen när man har en bebis och sen så känner man att nu fattar jag grejen så här.
Och lite så är det ju med ledarskap också.
När man har varit chef några år så tror man ju att man har håll på på läget.
Men det pågår ju så otroligt mycket i världen och tekniken och diskruption av både affärsmodeller och teknik och allting så att man måste ju hela tiden hålla sig uppdaterad och ha ett så här nyfiket och lärande mindset.
Och det är ju där vi någonstans kommer in och försöker erbjuda det på massa olika sätt men inte bara ge en så här one size fits all utan beroende på vad man vill finna sig då på sin resa som ledare eller som organisation så behöver man ju ta in, ibland behöver man bara ta in en konstult som jobbar med ledningsgruppen i några dagar liksom eller så behöver man ha en mer anmäld bara utbilda hela ledningsgruppen i AI eller så behöver man gå själv på en typ UGL för att fatta vem är jag i en grupp, vilken roll tar jag och hur påverkar mitt beteende andra människor.
Så oavsett var man befinner sig så ska vi finnas där.
Att kunna göra det går jag igång på.
Har ni som bolag en drömpersona som är det här är den magiska, inte ens level 5-chefen utan där är level 6-chefen det här är det vi ska uppnå med alla.
Eller har ni diskussioner om finns det en gyllene standard för chefskap hos er eller har ni olika åsikter?
Vi pratade förut om att vi behöver gå lite mer mot auktoritärt ledarskap.
Har ni de diskussionerna på kontoret eller är ni liknande er syn?
Det är väl det jag är ut efter.
Vi har ingen ideologi på det sättet att man ska stöpa alla i samma form, men det finns ju en väldigt...
Nu i sammanhang med 8 mars så gjorde vi ett upprop just kring det här att nu är det dags att höja rösten och stoppa det auktoritära macholedarskapet någonstans.
Vi ser en riktning mot det men vi tror på ett ledarskap som präglas av tillit och humanism.
Det är någonstans liksom så.
Men sen handlar det om att det är väl just nyfikenheten som man vill väcka.
Jag tror att alla som söker sig till oss är ju ändå på något vis nyfikna på att öppna och självgrannsakan att man vill utvecklas.
Det är väl den nyfikenheten man hela tiden vill utmana och utveckla.
Det finns en risk i det att man bara predikar för krören och vänder sig till de som redan är där.
Så det är klart att man kan inte heller bara prata om det, utan då behöver man ju, vi snackar mycket allt mer om att vi vill växa ledare som i sin tur växer affären eller resultatet eller organisationen.
Så det handlar ju om vad man jobbar.
Om du jobbar i offentlig sektor så pratar du inte om affär på det sättet, men du pratar om resultat.
Genom att växa och få ledare att utvecklas i sig själva så kommer också organisationen eller resultatet växa.
Det är väl det som är den hemliga modellen, att man förstår det sambandet på något vis.
Jag tycker bara att det är intressant för att det blir, om vi nu ska vara i sådana här, i Sverige får vi lite kritik för att alla håller med varandra och vi har någon sorts ultrakonsensuskultur.
Men då, jag fattar liksom vad du menar, att vi ska gå i någon sorts motståndsgrej.
Men det finns ju en ganska stor grupp som på något sätt tycker om det här med en auktoritär figur.
Eller i alla fall det är så man dras till i vad man läser eller liknande.
Gör man några tankar kring att här har vi en auktoritär cheffigur och så här jobbar man som auktoritär chef.
Förstår du vad jag är på väg med den?
Det finns med sådana modeller väldigt mycket.
Och apropå det här med den här klassiska frågan kring vad ska man säga än?
Ska man vara chef eller ska man vara ledare?
Där finns det ju en sån.
Ja, jag vill ha med den här frågan också.
Kan man säga chef nu i tiden?
Ja men exakt.
Och det är ju någonstans såhär att...
Då kan man ju tycka då, chef, då är du auktoritär, då är du en person som bara bestämmer sig ner i foten och ledar.
Det finns den här klassiska bilden, man ser på LinkedIn hela tiden med en chef står och piskar personer som drar en vagn och ledaren står längst fram och drar vagn och så.
Det är ju ett sätt att se på det.
Jag är rätt trött på det där, det är en diskussion för konsulter på LinkedIn.
Varje gång jag är med på en mässa eller står på en scen så kommer det fram någon management-konsult och vill ifrågasätta varför vi heter chef.
Jag har väldigt svårt att tro att det här är en fråga som vanliga chefer ägnar jättemycket tid om.
Men vi känner nog lite så här att chef är ju en position som du blir tilldelad, det är en roll.
Och ledare är typ en samling beteenden.
Det är inte ytterst slut varandra.
Du kan ju vara chef och vara sjukt dålig som ledare och du kan vara chef och vara jättebra som ledare.
Så någonstans, det hör ju ihop att vi heter chef, punkt också, den där punkten är ganska viktig att ha varit vid vår identitet.
Det är ju någonstans att också, det finns jättemycket chefsförrakt i samhället, det räcker ju att kolla på, ja men du vet, The Office och allting, är så här fumliga mellanchefer som är töntiga.
Det finns väldigt få som står upp för chefer i samhället.
Man kanske inte blir den roligaste killen på fest när man står och pratar om hur viktigt det är med chefer och så, men det är ju viktigt att någon driver den frågan och vi tar gärna den och har försökt ta tillbaka flaggan också över ordet chef.
Men då gäller det vad man fyller det med och då är det ju någon...
Man får ju vara ärlig och också säga att, jag var med i en annan podd nu som pratar mycket om det här maktbegreppet.
Man måste också inse och förstå att, för det är också något i det svenska tror jag, lite jantigt sådär att man, ja jag är chef men man kanske inte är så tydlig och man har svårt att sätta ner foten.
Du måste ju förstå att i din roll så ingår det också en makt och du påverkar andra människor jättemycket.
Det behöver man bara reflektera över och liksom så inse.
Men med det sagt så måste man ju inte vara auktoritär för det utan, det handlar väl om att vara så här, man behöver ju förstå någonstans att det blir mycket lättare att få igenom det du vill och de direktiven mål du din egen chef sätter för dig om du får med dig folk, snarare än att du liksom kämpar emot folk.
Så hur får man det då?
Då är det ju ett gott ledarskap.
Så jag tror att egentligen så, om den poletten trillar ner och man fattar det, då kanske också behovet av att vara auktoritär och så minskar lite.
Sen behöver man ju vara tydlig, det är ju annan, det märker vi också.
När man kollar, du frågade om forskningen så om det kom någon undersökning här, ganska nyligen över vad medarbetare hatar mest för sina chefer ungefär.
Då var det ju just så här att när chefer som är ineffektiva på att kommunicera, som ger otydliga instruktioner, var jag högst ut på listan.
Så där behöver man ju också fundera så här.
Det är det där, balansgången, att vara tydlig, men för den saken skulle man inte bara köra över folk, för då tappar man i roll.
Är det det som, för vi sa ju, eller du sa ju här innan, nästan alla chefer går runt och undrar typ, är jag bra eller kan jag detta typ, du vet impostergrejen.
Och åt andra hållet så är den största irritationen är, bara, fan kan du inte bara säga, prata rent typ.
Exakt.
Är det det chefer tror att de är dåliga på, eller vad är det chefer tror att de är kassa på generellt sett?
Stämmer de grejerna?
Ja, jag tror det är.
Alltså jag tror att det här, du landar i det här med, man har lärt sig på sina kursutbildningar, att vi ska jobba på det här sättet och vi ska ha konsensus och allt det där.
Det gör det svårt att vara tydlig, och det gör att chefer har svårt att hålla svåra samtal, det är man ju livräda för, det ser vi hela tiden.
Det finns så mycket utbildningar som helst, och så till och med sådana här digitala simuleringar, där du kan träna med någon AI-bot på att ha ett tufft samtal.
Jaha, det är ju ganska talande också, bara för att det är skitjobbigt.
Så, egentligen är det ju inte det, utan det är så här, man säger hur det är, så det är nog lättare än att man ska hålla på och linda in det.
Men det är också så jättesvårt att fatta beslut då, i osäkra tider, för att man kommer ju inte kunna ha alla med sig, man vet ju inte själv vad som ska hända, och ingen vet ju det, så ändå behöver man ju fatta beslut.
Så det är nog det man tycker är väldigt jobbigt, helt enkelt.
Men jag tror nog att tydligheten just skokar ändå ner till, jag tror själv, jag kan ju bara bjuda på det själv, så det är väl vad jag gör egentligen.
Jag är ingen ledarskapsexpert, men jag är ganska bra på att bjuda på mina egna grejer.
Otillräcklighet, precis som du också är i dina inlägg tycker jag.
Vi kanske har mycket otillräcklighet, så vi har en stor kassa att ösa från.
Jag har gått in coach nu faktiskt, och han sa till mig bara förra veckan i värdemöte, så jag sa kalla du känns som att du är ju ganska inlyssnande och härlig, du kan nog skruva upp tydligheten ett snäpp till.
Det blev min läxa till nästa gång vi ska ses.
Våga vara ännu mer tydlig.
Se vad som händer.
Så länge man har en, apropå det vi har pratat om nu, illit och vara en varm och genuin och empatisk person.
Om du har satt den grunden och tryggheten inom organisationen, då behöver man inte vara rädd för att peka med hela handen.
Men om det saknas, då blir ju folk jätteoroliga och så.
Så det gäller ju att bygga en grunda när man väl har gjort det, så kan man nog vara sådär.
Jag tror det där är liksom en, nu behöver vi lite terapi här men jag tror att man behöver ju hitta den balansen som är lagom och rätt för en själv.
Jag köper det och med risk för att jag inte vet vart jag är på väg med det här resonemanget, så jag får se om jag kommer att hamna fel här nu.
Men jag kan uppleva att det är samma sak.
Om man känner mig eller har pratat med mig, jag pratar ganska argt eller jag framstår som ganska karg som person i verkligheten.
Det är liksom min grej men jag har två små söner och när de är vid lekplatsen och bråkar, så som småpojkar gör ibland, så är jag ganska hård i när jag säger till dem, bara typ lägg av med det där, sätter ner, så här beter vi oss inte.
Jag låter ganska karg och jag kan se att jag då och då får någon blick från någon som tycker att jag tilltalar dem på ett väldigt argt sätt eller liknande.
Men mina pojkar blir ju aldrig rädda eller de blir aldrig ledsna utan de bara lyssnar, sätter sig ner och sedan fortsätter de leka.
Det finns ingen osäkerhet om jag älskar dem eller om jag ska gå längre än att höja rösten.
Det är så det funkar och det går lite på den här.
Det finns en tillit där mellan att jag älskar dem, de älskar mig, det är bara så här vi säger till och så att de lyssnar upp.
Så tycker jag att det kan funka inom företagen också.
Du gjorde fel här men om man vet att det är inte så att jag får sparken eller lägre lön för att jag gjorde fel, då är det bara en mening.
Den psykologiska tryggheten pratar man ju väldigt mycket om, det är det du lite beskriver.
Det är också det som jag läste hur ni jobbar med fellistor, där man delar med sig också av dem.
Det är rätt inspirerande tycker jag, att man inte ska vara så rädd för det.
Det är ju så och det finns ju sjukt mycket paralleller i det.
Det är också två grabbar, även om de är 15 och 13 nu, så de är inte så små längre, men det blir väl snarare...
Det är både och liksom.
Nej jag vill inte höra dem idag.
Det är svårare, men det är också roligt.
Min 15-anledning på att ta mått i körkort nu, det trodde man inte att man skulle hamna i.
Det är något nytt.
Nej, det är roligt.
Man får mer utav dem.
De blir också mer seniora medarbetare, så det blir roligare att jobba med sådana än totala nybörjare kanske.
Nej, men jag skulle säga att jag tror att...
Det finns verkligen en parallell här till arbetslivet, som du säger.
Men också, jag tror att man ska landa i det här som vi har snackat om, och sedan ser jag så till lite på det svenska ord, konflikter.
Det finns ju en stor konflikträdsla idé.
Det finns någon känsla i många organisationer att man är så himla rädd för grus och skav, och så fort man hittar ett skav, eller man hittar då grus i maskineriet, så ska det genast städas bort, och man tar in organisationskonsulter, och man ska försöka lösa det.
Folk söker till vidare från sina jobb till andra organisationer, för att man, man vill inte vara i den där, om det är bråkigt eller högt tonläge och så.
Men det tror jag, det är ju en D.
Det ska ju vara så.
Jag snackade med någon ledarskapsutvecklare som sa att den största röda flaggan han vet, det är när han kommer in i ledningsgruppen och allting är så här bra.
Alla är kompisar, det är jättehärligt, det finns inga problem.
Det är så här, oh oh, här har det ju stagnerat fullständigt.
Det är ju precis som det är en familj med barn eller en partner, det måste ju, ska det växa och utvecklas, så måste det ju skava lite.
Det är inget man ska jobba stenhårt för att ta bort, utan snarare kanske så här, man kan ju inte ska premiera det heller, det blir också jobbigt men...
Nej jag tänkte säga att jag ska slänga in lite skit här och där.
Man behöver kanske förstå att det är en naturlig del av all grupputveckling.
När det händer då förflyttas man och då händer det saker, det finns inget egenvärde.
Det kan lätt kanske som vd att man hamnar i den rollen, att man tror att rollen handlar om att vara nån slags medlare som ska gjuta olja på vågorna och lösa alla andras problem.
Det kanske också är så att de där skaven bygger ofta på ett sjukt stort engagemang och en förändringsvilja.
Då behöver man också vara lyhörd inför det och kanske också göra något av det, inte bara lägga locket på.
Vi snackade lite inför podden här och då pratar vi lite grann om att det kanske är svårt att hitta riktigt bra chefer som snackar om chefskap, utan det blir lätt konsulter, modeller eller liknande.
Men finns det några duktiga chefer som man kan lära sig av?
Du får inte säga Jan Karlsson, för det är väl, vad sa du, det är för många år sedan, vi kan inte läsa en bok.
Nej det verkar jobbigt exakt.
Nej men det finns ju, vi har ju då i tidningen Chefen någonting varje månad som kallar för cheftest.
Det är liksom vår största journalistiska granskning egentligen, där man liksom, jag menar med tropchefer.
Och då gör man, de reporterna som gör det då, då ringer man minst 20-30 personer som både jobbar med chefen och har jobbat med den och så tar man fram en ganska heltäckande bild av hur den personen är som chef.
Det var roligt.
Och sen betyg sätter man det utifrån nio olika chefer, nio punkter för ett bra ledarskap som man kan googla sig fram till om man är intresserad, men det är nio väldigt tydliga områden.
Och då handlar det om att vara en förebild, att kommunicera tydligt, att förmågan att leda sig själv, förmågan att utveckla team och rekrytera och beslutsfattande och motivation och konflikthantering och allt sånt där.
Det finns några områden och sen slutligen att nå resultat, för det är ändå det som någonstans handlar om.
Om man tittar nu bort från min fusklapp här, men om man tittar på de senaste, då blir det ju en ganska objektiv lista, annars är ju ledarskapet sjukt subjektivt.
Men enligt de parametrarna då, så är vi i topp på det som vi kallar för ledarligan.
Nu har han ju precis avgått då, men Claes Balkov som var vd för Axfood, han är en person som verkligen verkar vara en poppenchef.
Och sen är Riksbankschefen Erik Tedén, den ligger väldigt högt upp, det kan vara lite svårt att tro, för han kan ju framstå som ganska hård och träg.
Men han är tydligen väldigt rolig, kanonchef.
Han kan gå att ha medarbetare som inte förväntas i så hög humorgrad.
Om han kommer ut till lagret i Uddevalla har jag svårt att tro att han ska dra om gullfolk liksom.
Cultural fit för dig.
Nej men det är ju jättekul för vi testar ju folk.
VD för Krugliga Operan har hamnat väldigt högt upp.
Rasmus Erman som är vd och koncernschef på Apoteket.
Han är lite rising star i vår värld, ganska ung men också väldigt så.
Det finns ju ett antal personer som verkligen jobbar och tar ledarskapet på allvar.
Går det alltid bra chefer till stora bolag?
Detta är ju stora...
Kommer en duktig chef alltid fortsätta växa i organisationen?
Finns det riktigt bra chefer i små bolag eller tröttnar de?
Är det en grej?
Jätteintressant fråga, jag vet.
Det är underligt, apropå din tidiga fråga där om vad som egentligen driver den, där gissar jag att det är kanske lite skillnad.
Jag och även du, som jag har tolkat dig rätt, är ganska nöjd med att vara där vi är.
Det är inte tariären och synligheten.
Man behöver inte vara på omslaget på det i weekend, för det är inte det som är det endgame.
Det kanske snarare är att...
Jag gillar att du säger att du är chefredaktör för chef.
Chef, chefarnas chef.
Nej, men någonstans att...
Jag är väldigt luststyrd, det ska vara kul på jobbet.
Det ska vara lagom, mycket liksom.
Jag tycker man läser och ser och träffar så många chefer som jobbar, har...
Jag vill inte outa någon här, men jag träffade någon väldigt hög chef ganska nydligen som berättade att hon har väl 20 restdagar i Europa i månaden.
Och dessutom har man massa barn hemma och sen har man massa andra engagemang och styrelser.
Jobba 80 timmars veckor, det är ingenting som lockar mig.
Man behöver ha det där i sig, den drivkraften och viljan.
Det är väl ofta de som söker sig till de här större sammanhangen.
Jag tror inte det handlar om hur bra eller dålig man är som chef, utan det är nog mycket mer vad drivkraften är.
I de fallen är det nog väldigt mycket att förändra och resultatet, jag vet det du brukar skriva om också, det är kanske inte vinstmarginalen som är det absolut viktigaste, utan det är att känna den här känslan av progress och tillväxt ändå, men det är inte att det kan få ske, jag hade ju skriva någonting om vad det är en traktor som långsamt tuffar på, det kändes lite härligt.
Men sådär, att det där, ja det är ett riktigt intressant fråga, det måste ha gjorts forskning lite på vad det är för person, ledarskapstyper som hamnar vart egentligen.
Jag har inget kanonsvård.
Jag tänkte säga, när man, lite på samma tema som de här som lägger upp bilderna på chefen som sitter och piskar, på personerna som går längst fram, man har ju också läst att, hos VD'ar finns det en överrepresentation av, om det är psykopater eller narcissister, jag vet inte vilken, kanske både och då.
Men finns det några personlighetsdrag som man, när du ändå är inne på det, finns det några personlighetsdrag som man märker hos riktigt bra chefer?
Eller finns det några drag som man bara bör utveckla?
Jag började tänka när du sa det så började jag bara googla, det kan man roa sig med.
Apropå det här med chefförraktet i samhället, om man bara går in i Googlesökraten och skriver såhär min chef, och så bara ser man förslagen som dyker upp.
Det är såhär, min chef har mig att vara dåligt, min chef förminskar mig, min chef gillar inte mig, min chef ljuger för mig, min chef mobbar mig.
Och sen min chef är, då är det såhär, min chef är nazisist, är elak, är inkompetent, är altruist.
Alltså det är liksom någonstans inte en enda positivt kännetecken.
Så svaret på frågan är väl tvärtom från allt det där.
Men det är nog också att det är väl mycket att såhär, jag tror personligen, det blir så lätt också även här att hamna i såhär klishor och så, men att man behöver på något vis, riktigt bra chefer har landat i förståelsen att det inte handlar om dem själva och så, utan att det är på något vis ledarskap handlar om att få med sig människor för att nå verksamhetens mål.
Det är inte svårare än så, det är det som är det vi gör.
Det är ju en spännande take på chef, oavsett om du är chef på ett varuhus eller på ett företag som gör det du gör.
Du träffar ju supermånga i den här podden, olika entreprenörer, ledare i massa olika branscher och så.
Utmaningen är de samma, det handlar just om att få med sig människor för att nå resultat.
Det spelar ingen roll vilken, det är ju de här mjuka värdena.
Jag tror att de som har en grundförståelse i hur man får med sig människor, det är de som också lyckas skapa hållbara resultat på både kort och lång sikt.
Så jag menar det är ju någonstans det det krokar ner till.
Och då förstår man själv inte är, man behöver vara så pass mogen i sig själv och reflektera över sina egna beteenden.
Prata så som vi gör nu om just drivkrafter och ledarskap.
Om man inte gör det, jag tror väldigt få tar sig den tiden.
För det har inte pratats så mycket om men som man ska glömma det är ju att det är jättesvårt att vara chef idag eftersom jättemånga saknar förutsättningarna att göra ett bra jobb och man ser på typ offentlig sektor inte minst, det är inte alls ovanligt att man har 80 direkt rapporterande medarbetare.
Jag inte fan vet vad barnen och hunden heter och kommer ihåg födelse dagar.
Alltså det är ju jättesvårt, man saknar förutsättningarna.
Vi ska göra allt mer, alla chefer ska vara någon slags it-chefer och vara AI-experter.
Man pratar ofta om, man fyller hela tiden den här rollen med olika saker.
Det som är superhjälteideal nästan.
Den här ryggsäcken som man har, fylls bara på med mer och mer stenar samtidigt som vägen framför fötterna blir allt mer snårig och konstig för att världen är som den är.
Så det är ju, vad kan man egentligen förvänta sig?
Det känner jag själv också igen.
Det finns jättemycket förväntningar på en.
Där tror jag också att man behöver vara riktigt bra chef och landa i att man också är lite snäll mot sig själv.
Och känner att man gör så gott man kan.
Good enough kan vara ett självstående i många organisationer.
Men jag tror jättemycket på det som Michael Dahlén på Handelsningsskolan pratar om.
80-20 är regeln.
Man kan vara ganska nöjd med att du behöver inte leverera på topp hela tiden 100% utan leverera på 80%, det räcker.
Och då håller du också som i längden, du bränner inte ut dig.
Så jag tror att några saker som man nog bra chefer har fattat.
Det vill säga sådant som jag har fattat då.
Finns det några riktigt?
Om vi förutsätter folk som faktiskt försöker vara bra chefer nu, så vi skiter i alla som är dåliga, per definition.
Men finns det några dåliga grejer som bra chefer nästan alltid gör?
Dåliga grejer som bra chefer nästan alltid gör?
Det finns en massa enkla, typ att tippa till, aha, fan, man brukar ju säga att chefer tror att de snackar med sina kollegor en viss, att man ger feedback tillräckligt, blablabla, medan ingen typ kollega tycker att man ger feedback, trots att chefen, det är bara någon sån där grej jag har hört tusen gånger.
Finns det några mer sådana där grejer som, fan, det här är man allmänt kass på.
Men jag tror just det här som jag sa innan, att skruva upp tydligheten, att inte vara rädd för att framstå som för tydlig eller, för det blir också där när vi snackar om glidningen mot ett mer auktoritärt ledarskap, det innebär ju också att vi kanske blir rädda för att framstå som Trump.
Vi vill inte vara där, så då blir vi bara ännu mer mjäckiga, vilket nog är ett misstag.
Jag tror inte man ska vara så rädd för att vara tydlig.
Det är en sån där grej tror jag som man kan reflektera över.
Men sen tror jag ett jättevanligt misstag är att man är, men vi har ju alla människor en, vad säger man, will to please, alltså att man vill så gärna bli omtyckt, vilket gör att man också blir inkonsekvent, för man pratar med olika medarbetare på olika sätt.
Det är också något vi ofta premierar och säger, vi pratar om det här situationsanpassade ledarskapet, och man ska vara säker.
Men det kan också leda till att då pratar jag med någon person som är på ett visst scen, och säger något annat till någon annan för att ingen återredning, det ska man ska undvika grus och irritation och sådär, och då blir det jävligt otydligt.
Så att jag tror även där att ett tips jag fick var att man ska bara, allt man säger, nu spelar du ju in det här samtalet då, man ska tänka att alla samtal, alla telefonsamtal, alla möten, vad man än säger kan spelas in och spelas upp för någon annan i organisationen.
Om man bara har med sig det så är det en enkeltumregel man ska inte vara rädd av, men det gör ju att man kanske tänker på vad man säger på ett bättre sätt.
Jag tänkte säga att man inte kan tänka tvärtom också, att man tänker att ingen hör vad man säger, då blir man helt sig själv, var ärlig.
Men det kanske...
Jag tror också att det är en chef som jag hade, jag brukar ju påfatta om det, men bästa tipset jag har fått nästan, som också har gått runt...
Jag trodde du skulle säga något negativt.
Ja, vad synd.
Det kändes som om det var något riktigt dåligt på väg.
Jag tänkte, vad kul, då kan vi googla upp den här människan sen.
Hej, okej ja ja, berätta det här goda rådet.
Nej, det goda rådet förlåt, det är typiskt mig.
Men just att tänka som chef att man har en megafon framför munnen.
Det är så jävla lätt att man kanske inte i sin självkänsla tänker man inte att apropå att man ryter till eller man pratar extra högt eller man blir irriterad.
Man tänker att man nu ska vara jävligt...
Men någonstans som chef har du alltid en megafon framför munnen.
Du kan typ, believe me, du hörs ändå, du behöver inte ta i.
Och det är också någonting, tror jag, man har inte den självkänslan eller självförtroendet vilket mycket kokar ner till så tror man att man måste ta i med tårna.
Men bara rollen i sig innebär faktiskt ett ganska tydligt...
Det är ju makt som sagt, och du har ett mandat.
Ja, jag kan uppleva att det har blivit...
Vi ska inte hamna i massa jävla barnliknelser här, men jag kan uppleva att med tiden så får jag allt mer den känslan av att...
Ja men som...
Om man försöker vara chef eller vad man ska säga, då blir det rätt krystat.
Precis som att försöka vara förälder över sina barn är rätt krystat.
Det är inte så att de ifrågasätter den rollen.
Det är inte så att de bara...
Bara för att jag låter mina barn ta mer ansvar, eller göra det de kan göra, eller bli mycket bättre än mig på vissa grejer, så är det inte så att de slutar se mig som pappa.
Precis som mina kollegor inte kommer sluta se mig som chef, bara för att de är mer kompetenta inom ett område.
Utan mitt mandat ligger ju kvar.
Det är helt oförändrat.
På den tycker jag att det är en liknande.
Verkligen, och det är apropå det du frågade om innan, vad man ofta gör för misstag, så tror jag att just det där är en sån himla klassisk grej.
Det krokar väl också ner till självförtroende, men att man blir rädd för att inte vara den smartaste personen i rummet.
Att man hela tiden ska bränka sina medarbetare.
Man ska ha koll och man ska vara på toppen av spelet hela tiden i förhållande till sina medarbetare.
Istället för att vara helt lugn med att det är väl snarare tvärtom.
Det är inte ditt jobb att vara smartare än dina medarbetare.
Jobbet handlar om att ge dem rätt förutsättningar och bara göra sin grej så kommer det bli bra av sig självt.
Man behöver hitta den.
Det är något helt annat än vad många inbillar sig att de ska göra.
Just för att man ofta har fått sin självstål, för att man var den där experten en gång för tio år sedan.
Då tror man att man ska fortsätta vara det.
Jag förstår att du smailar för att du kanske känner igen känslan någonstans.
Ja, någonstans är det väl det.
Det är lätt att bli den där papygorgen.
Jag minns hur vi gjorde när jag hade din lov.
På min tids.
Det var en helt annan.
Det fanns typ inte en.
Det fanns.
Ett roligt exempel på det var att jag var ute förra året.
Då åkte jag runt jättemycket i Sverige och intervjuade modiga chefer.
Det var en satsning som vi hade.
Då skulle jag vara ute och intervjua en för första gången på typ tio år.
Så var jag skitnöjd och glad och kom.
Letade fram min gamla diktafon i en byrålåda.
Bytte batterier och så tog jag med den till jobbet.
Och så kolla vad jag hittade.
Den ska jag ta med mig nu.
Och så tittade Sofia, vår digitala redaktör, på mig och sa såhär, du vet om att man kan spela in i telefonen?
Jag bara, ja, det är riktigt.
Då gjorde jag det istället och hittade någon AI-tjänst som var svinbra och transkriberade allting.
Som hade tagit flera dygn tidigare, gjorde man på fem minuter nu.
Då insåg man att, okej, bilarna har förändrats.
Det är ju väldigt bra.
Jag tänkte bara ta en sista, men den kanske är lite svår.
Finns det en skillnad i, om du tänker bort att du säkert gör någon sur, finns det en skillnad i?
Man säger ju typ manligt och kvinnligt ledarskap, men jag skulle också vilja lägga in typ, men jag blev ju chef när jag var en liten lintott och såg väldigt ung och naiv och blyg ut.
Och nyss så ser jag ju ofta arg ut och får ofta en annan sorts feedback än vad jag fick förr, även om jag innombord kan tycka att jag är gladare och mer positiv nu.
Men jag bara menar, lär ni ut att man ska hantera sitt chefskap utifrån sina förutsättningar eller ifall man leder en viss, vad ska man säga, om jag leder folk i hamnen som låtsar container kontra folk i Miljöpartiets språkrum i Stockholm.
Alltså är det olika, hur pratar man kring chefskap i sånt här eller är det för känsligt att prata på det sättet?
Styrkan som vi har är att vi är så breda att ofta finns det branschorganisationer.
Du träffar nätverk med andra som gör samma sak som du.
Det är säkert jättebra men vi är på en utbildning hos oss så kan det vara just hamnchef, gatikörkschef, mediechef och vårdchef i samma rum.
Då pratar man om sina utmaningar och ger varandra coach, testar och så övar.
Vi pratar mycket om upplevelsebaserat lärande.
Fint ord men det handlar just om att utgå ifrån.
Ja men, träna liksom.
Det är inte bara att lära sig en fyrfältare som skriver ut en och står där i personalrummet och ska följa någon manual.
Det funkar ju inte så i verkligheten, utan man behöver ju träna på olika situationer.
Och då tror jag att när man är i en sådan miljö ofta, det finns ju också så här att vi tror ju mycket på att åka iväg, att faktiskt ta det i tiden att åka till en kursgård, stäng av telefonen, komma bort från det vanliga bryset och faktiskt ägna dig åt din egen utveckling.
Det är något man behöver liksom.
Det är rätt få som längtar efter mer tid med telefonen, utan man vill ju komma iväg och stänga av allt och fokusera.
Och då tror jag att det skapas en jäkligt snabbt, en otroligt trygg miljö där jag tror att man, eller jag vet att man också, men det blir inte så här som du beskriver att det blir obekvämt eller att man inte vågar prata om det, utan jag tror att i en sådan miljö så vågar man också, för man släpper ju på prestige än det är ingen vanlig kollega eller så där, utan man kan nog verkligen utgå från sig själv, men ändå utifrån vad man behöver.
Så det vi jobbar med är att försöka anpassa lite grann, men jag tror också att det finns ett stort värde i att man också har inser att som sagt, oavsett vilken bransch eller sektor du jobbar i så handlar det om.
Människor är inte så olika.
Oavsett om man jobbar på lagret eller i hamnen eller i en butik för styrreplan eller på en vårdcentral i smålhettan så gissar jag att det är någonstans samma dynamik.
Så man kan nog hitta många gemensamma nämnare.
Jag tänkte om ni fick inte kritik men att om du tog upp han, riksbankschefen här nu, TDN, TDN så kanske jag hade kunnat skriva att det är lätt för han att säga så här.
Det är klart att han kan prata på det, för han har en viss sorts dynamik i sin vardag.
Men du menar att det är i grundläggande att få med sig folk, är det ändå ungefär samma språk?
Men någonstans är vi ändå människor som vill bli bekräftade som liksom, klart att humor och jargon och kultur skiljer sig jättemycket åt.
Men oavsett så handlar det om att få med sig de människorna och få dem att prestera så bra som möjligt.
Då är ju chefens uppdrag att också vara, att själv vara, man ska förvara sig själv men också anpassa sig.
Det gör man ju hela tiden i alla situationer man är i så, så det är väl det att ha den förmågan att se vad som behövs för att få just den här gruppen att lyfta.
Men också se ifrån om man går över gränser och så där.
Att liksom hitta den, vad vill vi stå för?
Men nu nämnde jag som ett exempel, det är ju de här utbildningarna, men sen gör vi också mycket i många bolag.
Allt fler bolag idag har ju hem utbildning och utvecklingsinsatser och man kanske inte vill då skicka en person på kurs eller utbildning, utan då tar man in en konsult i sig själv.
Alltså man gör ett skräddarsytte eller företagsanpassat upplägg och så tittar man på vad behöver just er organisation och så tar man fram en lösning för det.
Det blir ju också, det märker vi att det är inte minst nu i lågkonjunktur och så ser man det som ett mer effektivt sätt.
Sånt gör vi ju jättemycket också.
Vi är väl lite agnostiker i religionen.
Det är lite samma för oss.
Man tar ett samtal, stämmer av behov och sen hittar man en lösning som funkar på både kort och lång sikt.
Så vi bor ju helst på.
Får jag ta en fråga till eller hinner du med det?
Jag gissar att man kan se lite trender i ledarskap.
Vi pratade lite grann om det.
Har du någon gissning om, absolut man ska väva in mer digitalt, absolut mer AI, men hur kommer det påverka?
Kan du se hur ledarskapet kommer påverkas framöver?
Helt plötsligt kan man få 500 människor på remote så att man blir inte lika emotionellt kopplad.
Vad ser du för trender i ledarskapet framöver?
Jag har ett nöje spredo om jag får göra ditt egen reklam här som heter Chef Weekly som kommer ut varje söndag som är gratis omvärldsspanning där jag sammanfattar veckans hetaste händelser.
Den där spanningen firade 100...
Vi kommer att länka det här nyhetsbrevet.
Det kommer jag att garantera att nämna den här podden i det nyhetsbrevet också när den kommer ut.
Men då gjorde jag när det var hundra utgåvor så bara stoppade jag in det i en klad och fick en svinbra rapport.
Sammanfattade utmaningar, det är det senaste årets trender men också vad man ser för egenskaper som behövs för chefer framåt.
När det gäller din fråga om AI och så, där ser man så himla tydligt att det skapar både jättemycket möjligheter men också sjukt mycket existentiell oro.
Och att det finns en risk...
Svenskarna och internet som är den stora studien som kommer varje år, den visade att AI-användningen 2024 var typ lika hög som 2023, men de som använde AI i 2024 gjorde det sjukt mycket mer än 2023.
Och vad det betyder är att vi håller på att skapa ett A-B-lag i användningen av ny teknik.
Det behöver man som arbetsgivare vara helt uppmärksam på.
Alltså att man ser till att inte bli omsprungen, att det finns vissa som verkligen fattar och andra som ligger helt efter.
Så det är en sån supertydlig trend.
Men sen är det ju liksom någonstans att slutsatserna var ju någonstans att allt vi ser nu med utmaningar i världen, det finns sjukt mycket paradoxer.
Jag har lyssnat på en intervju med Obama som sa att förmågan att hantera paradoxer är den absolut viktigaste delarinskapen just nu.
Då är det ju bland annat teknologi versus mänsklighet.
Alltså, AI och automation ökar.
Samtidigt ser vi att behovet av mänsklig kontakt växer.
Vi har massa nya digitala verktyg som gör att vi kan göra det här samtalet just nu.
Men det skapar också all generation för vi ses ju inte.
Det är en sån här supertydlig paradox.
Och sen finns det då till exempel så här, flexibilitet versus stabilitet.
Alltså vi pratar hela tiden om att vi måste ha så anpassningsförmåga, anpassningsbara, vi måste vara så flexibla.
Och samtidigt ser vi att människor söker trygghet och röstar på typ auktoritära ledare.
Det går ju inte ihop och därför måste ju ledare då vara slutsatsen i den här rapporten att man måste vara tvåhänt, alltså ambidexter i sitt ledarskap.
Man måste kunna vara både, så här ha en djup teknisk förståelse och förmåga att ha hög EQ, emotionell intelligens och kunna inbjuda hopp hos sina medarbetare.
Och sen måste man satsa på lärande.
Alltså man måste förstå att vara nyfiken i sig själv och förstå att man måste upskilla och reskilla sig i allt vad det heter.
I vardagen får man överleva på arbetsmarknaden.
Organisationen måste fatta det, vill man behålla de här medarbetarna så måste man satsa på deras utveckling.
Det var i stora drag de trender man ser helt enkelt.
Fan det är härligt.
Jag var rädd att du inte var en passionerad typ utan att vi skulle sitta här och fastna i någon sorts...
Discus.
Ja, men någon sorts tröttsamt grej om att ja det är viktigt med...
Jag vet inte, någonting.
Jag vet precis vad du menar.
Det är ju, vi brukar prata om det, att vi går med machete genom floskeljungeln.
Alltså det är ju så otroligt mycket snömos och klyschor också i den här världen och jag försöker anstränga mig, så vet inte hur bra jag lyckas, det får väl lyssnarna avgöra, men man försöker att anstränga sig med att inte bara slänga ut sig en massa klyschor och floskler hela tiden, utan försöker vara någorlunda genuin.
Det är väl målet i alla fall.
Underbart.
Kalle, stort, stort, stort tack för att du tog dig tid att vara med och prata.
In och prenumerera på Kalles nyhetsbrev och följ hans podd som heter...
Vist och flör.
Det är jag och min kollega Annika Kvist som snackar om ledarskap varje vecka.
Så gör det.
Tack så mycket.
Tack.
Jag blev chef när jag var en liten lintåtta och såg väldigt ung och nejv och blyg ut.
Och nu så ser jag ofta arg ut.